thanks for hanging out with us America
we're so glad you're here this is the
Dave Ramsey chef
Nina is whether it's in Canada honey how
are you hi um thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um I need a new way to
approach my very male husband and an
issue that we're facing with our 18 year
old son and it's in regards to cellphone
if our son is out of province going to a
small Bible College because he's
planning to become a pastor and arson
he's having really big he's having
trouble with self control in his life it
not only is in regards to his cell phone
there's a few other areas of his life
and he went we took him out to college
near the beginning of September and one
of the lessons that my husband talked to
him and he said to my husband because
their cell phone bill would do we have a
bundled plan for my husband's and mine
and his his phone he he told it he told
us that oh I bought something on my on
my phone and I'm over and basically his
Gen the general gist of it well you know
I know I'm over and you and basics and
well basically cover it basically and
the problem is this is not the first
time he's going repeatedly over and he
knows what his limit is and I need a
fresh way a to approach my husband so
that we're on the same team we're on the
same page and I also own our son Bryan
he's our strong-willed child we also I
also need a fresh way when he comes home
on semester break at the end of October
to be able to approach him about it so
that we don't just get the backup but
that he actually hears us I tried to
approach my husband because for me I in
some ways I think because of Bryan
is his struggles with self-control in
other areas of his life to me I think
this is we're giving the quote/unquote
drunk a drink but and I think some of
what feeling my husband's desire is both
my husband and I have a blended family
situation that wasn't exactly healthy
when we both left home in our early
after we graduated from high school
and my husband wants to be there for his
son and support and encouragement and so
he's your husband thinks is okay right
I'm trying to make sure I get the
picture your husband thinks this is okay
and you know bottom line I think so I
don't and it is really hard sometimes to
get that out of my husband to know where
he's coming yeah I guess you guys you
sit on the back listen you're upselling
back porch have a discussion with your
husband I know what's going on there I
mean you know turn off the TV turn off
all the other white noise get on the
back porch or wherever it is you go when
you do that go for a walk I don't care
we go look this is driving me freakin
nuts because you know you are completely
buying heroin for a heroin addict over
here this kid is out of control
and you are Woodson and it's driving me
nuts so what are you thinking you know
you got to talk to him where you can
hear you and you know and it's making me
my brain is coming I'm just my hair's on
fire right here I can't stand this and
you know just see what he says then get
you get your husband going and then you
guys come to a conclusion as to what you
guys want to do and how hard you want to
come down on some of these different
things the thing that's disturbing me
more than the cellphone thing is you
keep mentioning these vague references
to other areas of lack of self-control
that you keep driving by and I don't
know what that is don't really care but
this is just one in a pattern of Miss
behaviors that this little boy is not
becoming a man mm-hmm
is what amounts to and so being in
control of yourself is part of manhood
part of what part of womanhood you know
and it's called freaking growing up and
time to do it Bubba you're 18 and to the
extent that you don't do things the way
I want you to whether you're 18 with
your 28 or whether you're
I start taking things away from you that
I'm giving you
mm-hmm and your life's going to change I
mean no Bible College no cell phone no
pants yet to buy your own you know and
you got a whole new turf or different
life here so you're going to do either
by persuasion me persuading you and
explaining to you what manhood looks
like and you're going to walk in that
you're going to do within within
reasonable levels of grace what what I'm
saying when in the way I think things
are or I'm not funding you're crazy but
hey you know I don't fund crazy I don't
I don't buy I don't fund misbehaviour
that makes me out of line then now is
this is just simple thing the kid went a
few dollars over and you're being a
Pharisee you need to back up and maybe
your husband is going to tell you that I
don't know yeah but if there's a whole
pattern of this guy misbehaving and
you're just being too hard or are you
just being too hardcore I don't know I'm
not a Family Therapist y'all got to look
at that sit down talk to your pastor and
figure this out you know are you are you
trying to get the screws tightened down
so tight that you don't give the guy any
room to be a person because mom's a
freak you know is if that's I don't know
if you're that I don't not accusing you
that okay I'm just saying you start
asking yourself these kinds of questions
that's questions I ask myself you know
you know god help you if you're Dave
Ramsey's kid you know in assuming Dave
Ramsey's a good guy you know that you
got a big shadow right now and I have to
ask myself about that with my kids what
do you know it's a blessing to be my
kids also freaking curse think about it
you know so I got to think about that
and how I'm interacting with them and
you got to think about that with with
Brian as well so are you asking
unreasonable things and is that what
your husband's trying to say with his uh
passivity in this situation or you know
or are you in line and your husband's
just being worse and that these are the
things you've got to talk through with
him you guys get on the same page it's
probably a little bit of all of that
probably Brian's out of line you may be
running too tight your husband may be
running too loose and maybe we need to
pull the three of you together towards
the center of this whole thing maybe I
don't know
you couldn't just be Brian's been a
little twerp and y'all need to pop him
you know you know oh not that we all
have ever been a twerp
yeah I mean not we all have you know I'm
18 years old you would think I wasn't oh
my gosh that's not the question but
we're not talking about me that's not
what this calls about right
it's called about Brian so you know
what's he going to do and Wow
the question is this not how you can
control his cell phone bill but what's
going to cause him to be the man he
needs to be five years from today
hey and that that's what we're trying to
be I mean he's going to Bible College
the man of God that he wants to be five
years from today and what is the process
it takes him there I mean one of the
fruits of the spirit self-control so
let's see some Holy Spirit involvement
here and so you and your husband you're
right you got to just talk this through
and I just think some real plain talk
about it and your personal frustration
and then you go is that me am I being
over-controlling or are you being a wuss
and that's you talking to your husband
you know and this is how we talk around
our house I mean we just we talk about
things to be unclear is to be unkind
because you get really frustrated with
all these niceties and nobody knows what
the flip people are talking about in all
their subtleties so just talk it through
with him and go okay what is going to
cause Brian to be the man of God he
needs to be is it some more grace and
some room or is it that we need to put
up some little tighter boundaries
because the kids misbehaving and you
know the question is not whether we can
afford the stupid overage of $100 or
whatever the question is the pattern of
behavior in the kid's life and is that
something we're going to finance you
can't keep him from doing it but you can
you can make his life miserable if he
keeps doing it and you know I want to
help him have some problems as my friend
Henry cloud says you know if he had any
problems we'll help him have some hey
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you enjoyed
that video from the Dave Ramsey show if
you want to watch another great video
check out my video three things you
should consider renting right over here
or click the link in the description
below